- So now, if you,
if you gave 10 bucks
maybe your account can be
freezed by your own bank.
You know, you do that
in a communist country.
In a communist country. Not
supposed to happen in Canada.
But Justin Trudeau is
doing that right now.
You don't need to use
these kind of powers
to be able to solve
the situation,
to resolve the situation
in Ottawa right now.
(ethereal instrument music)
- I'm Dave Ruben and joining
me today is the founder
and leader of the
People's Party of Canada,
Maxime Bernier.
Maxime, old friend, welcome
back to The Ruben Report.
- Thank you very much.
Very pleased to be with you.
- I wish we were talking
under better circumstances,
but unfortunately
the man who is your Prime
Minister up there in Canada
has exercised these
emergency powers.
We're gonna get
into all of that.
And you've really
been at the forefront
of fighting for freedom
from a Canadian perspective,
for many, many years.
I thought I could just throw
to one video real quick up top,
because I've had you on
the show a couple times
over the years.
First time was about three
years ago this month.
And we did an event together
about two and a half years ago
in Canada and, and
ANTIFA showed up.
And a bunch of sort
of hysterical lefties,
who have seemingly taken over
your government, showed up.
And I think a bunch of
people will remember this.
- [Woman chanting] Nazi
scum, off the streets.
Nazi scum, off the streets.
(chanting continues)
Don't touch me.
Do not touch me.
- All right, so the
reason I started with that
is because you have been
talking about freedom
and liberty and choice
and individual rights
in Canada for many years.
That right there,
that woman yelling,
you know, "You're Nazis",
et cetera, et cetera,
yelling it to a woman, whose
husband who is next her
actually fought against
Nazis in World War II.
That has been much
of the response.
And it seemingly has leaked
into your government now.
So I thought that would be a
good place to start us off.
- Yeah, absolutely.
You're right.
You know the world culture,
it's all in Ottawa
right now in Parliament.
And as you know,
Justin Trudeau said to the
protestors that are in Ottawa,
and I was there the
last two weekends,
that they're racist
and xenophobe.
And he tried to discredit the
people that are participating
in that protest.
I call that a rally, you
know because I was there,
people were smiling.
That was fun, dancing
on the street,
and it was fun
because these people that
were there understand
that the end of all these
mandates is happening.
And right now, you know, in
certain provinces in Canada,
like Saskatchewan,
Alberta, Quebec,
they will lift all their
mandates this month.
So it's only the federal
government that is saying,
"No no no, we need to put more
restriction on your freedoms"
with that Emergencies Act that
Trudeau use this this week.
- How closely are you
associated with the truckers?
It's a little hard to
tell how these groups
are all associated,
who is coordinating
all of this stuff,
but clear in two weeks they
made a lot of forward movement.
As you just said, some of
the premieres started saying,
"Hey we're gonna scale
this stuff back."
Trudeau then had a moment
to say, "Okay, let's do it.
Let's relax on this stuff."
And instead he put
his foot on the gas.
- Yeah. He doubled down.
He doubled down on restrictions,
and you know there's no
emergency in Canada right now.
And you know, if you
use that Emergencies Act
you must show the
threshold is very high.
And you must show that we
are in a war in Canada.
There's insurrection in Canada,
or democracy's in danger.
That's not the case.
And a lot of experts, legal
experts said this week
that there's no justification
for Justin Trudeau
to use that Emergency Act.
And actually the
premier of Quebec,
the premier of Alberta,
the premier of Saskatchewan
said to Trudeau, "We don't
want you to use these powers.
We don't need that Act.
And we don't want
that in our province."
But Trudeau didn't listen,
and he went and he used it.
And now, you know, in
Ottawa the police will act
and I don't know
what can happen.
But that protest
was very peaceful
and people were happy to
be there and we'll see.
But Trudeau has one
solution that he can use,
and that would be
very, very effective.
It's to end the mandates
at the federal level.
Actually, as you know
I cannot travel in my
own country by plane
because I'm not double vaxxed.
That's unconstitutional
and illegal.
And that's why I'm suing right
now the federal government,
because of that.
But Trudeau can
end that tomorrow.
There's no scientific
reason for that.
There's no justification
for that, but no,
he's doubling down
with that legislation.
- So I get that
guys like you and I
maybe are in a little bubble.
We love freedom.
We're around an awful lot of
people who like to live freely.
I know it's a very radical idea,
but do you have a sense of who
is really supporting Trudeau?
I don't see many people
actually supporting him.
Even just personally
looking online,
I don't see a lot of
support for Justin Trudeau.
I don't see a lot of support
for exercising these
emergency powers.
I see an awful lot of pushback,
but I don't see the
people that are like,
"Yes, he is doing it right.
And these people are
racists and you know,
they should have their heads
crushed by the government."
- No, the way that he
is managing that crisis,
he didn't have a lot of
support from the population.
And actually we are
growing our support.
We, the People's
Party, you know,
we created that party in 2018.
Our first election was in 2019.
We had 1.6% of the vote.
Our second election last
September 5% of the vote.
And now the last poll this week
we're supposed to be around 10%.
So we are growing. Our
support is growing.
But for Trudeau the way
that he managed that crisis,
for him it's a power
grab, that's it.
And I believe that more and
more Canadian understand that.
And I don't, if we have
an election tomorrow,
it won't be good
for Justin Trudeau.
- What do you think
his endgame here is?
I mean, he's obviously
scared a lot of people
and I want to talk to you
about what your Deputy
Prime Minister said.
Obviously, Chrystia Freeland,
who you know gave this just
unbelievably, awful speech
and that they're gonna freeze
bank accounts and all that.
But before we get to that,
what do you think
his real endgame is?
Is this purely,
"I'm gonna scare the
hell out of these people.
Enough of them will disappear,
and my reign of power
will just continue."
Is that, is it as
simple as that?
- It may be something
like that, but you know
it's very difficult to
understand what he wants to do.
Actually, what we
know is for being sure
that the thing that a
bunch of violent people
are in a Ottawa right
now, and that's not true.
And more and more people
understand that it's not true.
And actually, as you
know, the bridge,
the Ambassador Bridge, we
had a protest over there
and the police was able
to solve that peacefully.
And now the bridge is open.
So without adding
Emergencies Act enforce.
So I don't know.
Trudeau, like he said during
the last electoral campaign,
he is very good at
devising the population.
Good Canadians
and bad Canadians.
And for him the good one
are the one that
are listening to him
and having the two
shots or three shots
and all these mandates
and Canadians that want
to have more mandates.
And that must stop. But no,
he is doubling down on that.
- And it's worth mentioning
that Trudeau was
reelected not too long ago
with less than a third
of the popular vote.
That's just an important
little piece to say.
So when the Deputy Prime
Minister got up there, Freeland,
and said this thing about how
they will freeze bank accounts
for people who donate
to the truckers.
That they're gonna make sure
that they cannot crowdfund.
That they're gonna figure
out ways to regulate
cryptocurrency and a
series of other things.
First off, I don't that
they can do all that stuff.
I mean, regulating crypto.
The whole point of crypto is
so that you can't regulate it.
But putting that aside,
I can imagine that
that the average person
that is out there
with you in Ottawa,
the average truck driver,
who these are not wealthy
people for the most part.
They're just, you know,
decent working class people,
they get scared,
they get scared.
And then suddenly they
don't want donate.
They don't want to be
photographed out there.
And maybe that threat does
enough to end this thing.
- Yeah, but you know it's sad.
It's very sad that in Canada
you use that kind of
power to, you know.
These people that are
giving to the truckers
are not terrorists.
They're not part of
being in a violent,
you know, actions or
something like that.
They're giving money
to the truckers
because they believe in freedom
and they want to get
regain their freedoms.
That's it.
So now if you, if
you gave 10 bucks
maybe your account can be
freezed by your own bank.
You know, you do that
in a communist country.
In a communist country. Not
supposed to happen in Canada.
But Justin Trudeau is
doing that right now.
You don't need to use these
kind of power to be able to,
to solve the situation,
to resolve the situation
in Ottawa right now.
- Do you think, I mean,
at the end of the day
I know he's head of
the Liberal Party,
and we've often talked about
classical liberalism together,
but this man is no liberal in
any real sense of the word.
He's either a socialist
or a communist,
or a fascist I would
argue at this point.
What do you think
really drives him?
What do you think is really
driving him at this point?
Because he did not
have to do this.
There was a moment
a few days ago
where some of the
premieres were saying,
"We're gonna scale back."
And clearly you guys were
gonna hear the message.
It was obvious.
But he didn't, as I said.
So what do you think he really
is trying to accomplish?
- Well I believe that,
you know, power grab.
I believe that he enjoyed
the fact that he can have
all these power and putting
more restriction on our rights.
I believe that he is acting
like a communist
dictator right now.
And I believe that
he's enjoying that.
Because there's no
reason to use that,
and to do that, to stop that.
There were very to
stop the protests
at the Ambassador
Bridge peacefully.
So you can do that.
And the answer is,
end all these mandate.
And provincial
governments in Canada
are listening to the truckers
and ending all these mandate,
except the federal government.
It's, you know, there's
no logic in all that.
And I hope because the
Parliament will have to vote
on that legislation next week.
And I hope it won't pass.
If it doesn't pass,
it would be the end.
If that legislation, that
Emergency Act is enforced,
Trudeau will have another 30
days to use all these power.
If not, that would be the end.
And I hope we still have
political parties in Ottawa,
in Parliament, that
believe in freedom
and believe in our country.
And I hope that
they're gonna say "No"
to Justin Trudeau next week.
- Are you hopeful that
the Conservative Party,
you guys have a
Conservative Party
that is not really conservative.
It's sort of, it's
sort of liberal,
but that's for a whole
other conversation,
but are you confident
that perhaps you guys
and the more liberty-minded
people can guide them properly?
It does seem maybe at some
level that this Candice Bergen,
who's now heading the
party is at least,
at least pretending to
be a little for freedom?
- Yes, she's pretending,
but we'll see.
Actually as you know,
Trudeau doesn't have the
majority in Canada in Parliament
and he will need another
party to pass that.
And the NDP, the strong leftist,
said that they will
vote with Trudeau.
So that may pass in Parliament
and you still have
the Senate in Canada,
and maybe the Senate will
be able to stop that.
But I don't count on the
Conservative Party anymore.
Like you said, they're
intellectually, morally corrupt.
They're not conservative.
They're doing politics
based on survey.
They don't have any conviction.
They were not there
the last two years.
I was alone fighting
for freedom.
Doing some rallies, being out
there speaking with Canadians.
But the Conservative, they
agreed with everything
that Trudeau know did
for the last two years.
- I know you don't want
extra credit for this,
cause I know you as a friend,
but you actually got arrested,
what about a year ago?
The video, you took the
video as it was happening.
It was pretty extraordinary.
You know, we'll we'll
lay it in right here
so people can see.
- [Officer] Afternoon, sir.
We're in part with the RCMP.
If I can get you step
outta the vehicle,
I'm going to place you
under arrest right now.
Right now you're under arrest
under the Provincial
Health Orders.
Okay. So if you can just put
your hands behind your back,
face towards vehicle.
Okay. Gimme one hand here.
- [Second Officer] I'll get
your signature okay? Thank you.
- [First Officer]
The other hand.
Do you have any weapons
or anything on you, sir?
- Weapon? No. No
weapon. Only my words.
[Officer] Anything on
you that's gonna hurt me?
Or anything like that?
- Sorry?
[Officer] Anything on
you that's gonna hurt me
or anything like that?
- No. No anything will
hurt you, only my words.
Only my philosophy.
Only what I believe in.
- [Officer] Okay.
Alright. Come on over this way.
I'll explain a few things
to you here right away.
- That moment for you,
and what you said
was just so perfect.
So beautiful.
Your words are what you have.
That's what they
fear, in essence.
This can't be fun.
This can't be fun, what
you're going through there.
- Yeah. I didn't expect that.
You know, after rally in
a park, being arrested
and put in jail for 12 hours,
for a non crime in Canada.
That happened last summer.
And like I said, in my speeches,
I'm ready to go back to jail,
to fight for our freedoms.
And I will always fight for
what is good for this country.
- Maxime, what can
people do to help?
You know, obviously
we're trying to amplify
the message here.
People are trying to
help with crowdfunding,
whatever they they can do.
And it has nothing to do with
supporting racists or bigots
or homophobes or transphobes
or any of the other nonsense.
Which is exactly why I
played that video up top,
cause that's what they
were yelling about us
three years ago.
What else can we do to help?
- Well first of all, they
can follow me on Twitter
@MaxineBernier.
They can also go on our website,
peoplespartyofcanada.ca
They can donate.
They can help us.
This new political party
is growing step by step.
And I believe that the
future will be better for us,
for Canadians, if we
have more support.
But our support is growing.
So they can go and
read our platform.
They're gonna see that
we have a platform
that is based on, for
principle, individual freedom,
personal responsibility,
respect and fairness.
Thank you for giving
me that opportunity
to speak to you and
with your viewers.
- Maxime, I know you will
always fight for Canada
but I want you to know
that I've got an
extra guest room here.
If you ever consider political
asylum, Florida ain't bad.
But I know you wouldn't do it
cause I know you're gonna
fight for your country.
- I appreciate that.
Thank you, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.